one in Ian's woods is in New York forest
the verdict has come in in the Harvey
Weinstein sex assault trial and he has
been found guilty
Ian's tell us more he's been found not
guilty of the two most serious charges
but three guilty verdicts in the lesser
charges let me run those through for you
now the two most serious charges were
predatory sexual assault or two women
Miriam Haley in 2006 and Jessica man in
2013 he has been found not guilty of
those charges but he has been found
guilty of the criminal sexual assault in
the first degree of Miriam Haley raped
in the first degree of Jessica man and
rape in the third degree of Jessica man
now those charges that he's been found
guilty of carry a maximum prison
sentence of 25 years and a minimum we
believe of five years so Harvey
Weinstein has been found guilty of these
three charges it was a complex case
because even though there were dozens of
allegations being made in the media by
various women about Harvey Weinstein
over the last two and a half years and
so vehicles first started appearing in
the media about it
prosecutors in New York had to select
what they felt were the cases that they
felt were the best chances of getting
criminal convictions so they selected
the cases of Miriam Haley and Jessica
man but their stories about being
attacked by Harvey Weinstein were backed
up by testimony from other women who had
similar allegations to make but in some
cases those allegations happen so long
ago that they would not have been
legally admissible but they were heard
in court to be able to backup this Nate
this this claim of a predatory sexual
nature but the jury apparently have not
been convinced of that they came back on
Friday afternoon after around 20 hours
of deliberations through last week to
say that they were deadlocked on those
two most serious charges and the judge
told them to still go away and think
about it have the weekend to relax and
then come back and make their decision
on Monday morning they have done that
after just a couple of hours
deliberation this morning and now we
await for the reaction from the lawyers
afterwards
wouldn't expect our Harvey Weinstein to
be sentenced today so we don't know
whether he will come out of this court
building whether he will still be bailed
pending his sentence but certainly his
lawyers will react and they will almost
certainly appeal against these guilty
convictions
you